what are some of the biggest stuff you
attempted to explore how to build in a
lab sure so viewed from One Direction
what we're talking about is a crazy
random seeming of almost unrelated
projects but if you rotate 90 degrees
it's really just a core thought over and
over again just very literally how bits
and atoms relate how digital and just
going from digital to physical in many
different domains but it's really just
the same idea over and over again
so to understand the biggest things
uh let me go back to uh bring in now
Shannon as well as Von Neumann yeah so
what is digital
the Casual obvious answer is digital in
one and zero but that's wrong there's a
much deeper answer which is
Claude Shannon at MIT wrote the best
Master's thesis ever in his master's
thesis he invented our modern notion of
digital logic
where it came from was Van ever Bush uh
was a grand old man at MIT uh he created
the post-war research establishment that
led to the National Science Foundation
and he made an important mistake which
we can talk about
but he also made the Le the differential
analyzer which was the last great analog
computer so it was a room full of gears
and pulleys and the longer it ran the
worse the answer was
and Shannon worked on it as a student
and he got so annoyed in his master's
thesis he invented digital logic
um but he then went on to Bell labs and
what he did there was
communication was beginning to expand
there is more demand for phone lines and
so there's a question about how much how
many phone lines you could phone
messages you could send down a wire
and you could try to just make it better
and better he asked a question nobody
had asked which is rather than make it
better and better what's the limit to
how good it can be and he proved a
couple things but one of the main things
he proved was a threshold theorem for
channel capacity and so what he showed
was my voice to you right now is coming
as a wave through sound and the further
you get the worse it sounds but people
watching this are getting it as as in
from packets of data in a network
um when they get when the computer
they're watching this gets the packet of
information
um it it can detect and correct an error
and what Shannon showed is if the noise
in in the cable to the people watching
this is above a threshold they're doomed
but if the noise is below a threshold
for a linear increase in the energy
representing our conversation the error
rate goes down exponentially
exponentials are fast there's very few
of them in engineering and the
exponential reduction of error below a
threshold if you restore state is called
a threshold theorem
that's what led to digital that that
means unreliable things can work
reliably so Shannon did that for
communication then van Neumann
was inspired by that and applied it to
computation and he showed how an
unreliable computer can operate reliably
by using the same threshold property of
restoring state it was then forgotten
many years we had to ReDiscover it in
effect in the quantum Computing era when
things are very unreliable again
but now to go back to how does this
relate to the biggest things I've made
so
in fabrication MIT
invented computer-controlled
Manufacturing in 1952. jet aircraft were
just emerging there is a limit to
Turning cranks on a machine on a milling
machine to make parts for jet aircraft
now this is a messy story MIT actually
stole computer controlled Machining from
an inventor who brought it to MIT wanted
to do a joint project with the Air Force
and MIT effectively stole it from him so
it's kind of a messy history but
that sounds like the birth of
computer-controlled Machining 1952.
um there are a number of inventors of 3D
printing one of the companies spun off
from my lab by Max lebowsky's form Labs
which is now a billion dollar 3D
printing company that's the modern
version
but all of that's analog meaning the
information is in the control computer
there's no information in the materials
and so it goes back to Van ever Bush's
analog computer if you mistake make a
mistake in printing or Machining just
the mistake accumulates
the real birth of computerized digital
manufacturing is four billion years ago
that's the evolutionary age of the
ribosome
so the way you're manufactured is
there's a code that describes you
the genetic code it goes to a micro
machine the ribosome which is this
molecular Factory that builds the
molecules that that are you
the key thing to know about that is it
there are about 20 amino acids that get
assembled and in that Machinery it does
everything Shannon and taught us you
detect and correct errors so if you mix
chemicals the error rate is about a part
in a hundred
when you make elongate a protein in the
ribosome it's about apart and 10 to the
four when you replicate DNA there's an
extra level of error correction it's a
part in 10 to the eight and so in the
molecules that make U
you can detect and correct errors and
you don't need a ruler to make you the
geometry comes from your parts
so now compare a child playing with Lego
and a state-of-the-art 3D printer or
computerized milling machine
uh the Tower made by a child is more
accurate than their motor control
because the act of snapping the bricks
together gives you a constraint on the
joints
you can join bricks made out of
dissimilar materials you don't need a
ruler for Lego because the geometry
locally gives you the global parts and
there's no Lego trash the parts have
enough information to disassemble them
those are exactly the properties of a
digital code the unreliable is made
reliable yes absolutely so what the
ribosome figured out four billion years
ago is how to embody these problems
these digital properties but not for
communication or computation in effect
but for construction
so a number of projects in my lab have
been studying the idea of digital
materials and think of a digital
material just as Lego bricks the precise
meaning is a degree discrete set of
Parts reversibly joined
um with global geometry determined from
local constraints and so it's digitizing
the materials